whether they were brought in at the last
minute or just didn't feel like doing
the required reading these actors found
themselves unprepared for their iconic
or inFAMOUS performances
taika waititi admitted that he didn't
prepare much to play Adolf Hitler in the
quirky 2019 drama JoJo rabbit which he
also wrote and directed in many ways
this lack of preparation helped
characterize his wacky version of the
evil dictator waititi told deadline that
the version of Hitler in the film was a
child's imaginary friend not the
detestable historical figure he
elaborated I didn't have to do any
research and I didn't do any research I
didn't base him on anything I'd seen
about Hitler before I just made him a
version of myself that happened to have
a bad haircut and a shitty little
mustache and a mediocre German accent
people used to say a lot of nasty things
about me oh this guy's a lunatic oh look
at that psycho he's gonna get us all
killed YTD hadn't originally planned to
cast himself in his adaptation of the
children's book caging Skies but the
studio pushed for it he told variety you
start thinking of bigger stars to be
part of a film like this or to play an
imaginary Hitler but at the end of the
day it came down to the simple fact that
if we had done that that would have
overshadowed the heart of the story
which is this beautiful story this
relationship story between these two
kids it's hard to imagine a 10 year old
Hitler Youth remember as the protagonist
of a heartwarming story but waititi
walked the tightrope with JoJo rabbit
why TD ended up winning the Oscar for
best adapted screenplay despite not
doing a lick of research while writing
his satirical role busy movie stars have
to frequently act like air traffic
controllers shifting their schedules to
accommodate Productions that have their
own shifting schedules that's what
happened to Anna De armas when she found
herself caught between Bond and a blonde
first the cuban-born actress spent a
year preparing to portray Marilyn Monroe
and Netflix's blonde when production
dates shifted de armas jumped at the
chance to also appear in the James Bond
film no time to die even if it meant she
wouldn't have time to properly train she
told Entertainment Weekly I went to
London and I only had like 10 days to
two weeks of training which is not much
for everything I had to do which made me
very nervous before long Daniel Gregg
suffered an injury so the bond shoot was
postponed and day armas went back to
playing Monroe in the drama when it was
time to get back to the realm of English
Espionage she had to rely on muscle
memory I I forget things when I get
nervous
this is the biggest job I've ever had
the arm is submitted to Harper's Bazaar
I didn't have the time to actually
commit to any kind of diet or workout or
training because my schedule just didn't
allow for it those few days that I did
have some training it was a short but
really intense immersion into the bond
universe so I quickly transformed into a
CIA agent
Vigo Mortensen had very little time to
prepare to play Aragorn in The Lord of
the Rings The Fellowship of the Ring
Mortensen was cast after filming had
already begun director Peter Jackson
fired Stuart Townsend one day before
filming began replacing the Irish actor
with Mortensen at the last minute
Mortensen was initially quite reluctant
to take on the role as he hadn't read
the books and had no time for
Preparation but his son Henry a big fan
of tolkien's work convinced the actor to
take the role Mortensen only really had
the flight to New Zealand to prepare
according to Showbiz cheat sheet the
actor said I relaxed a bit as I started
reading the book but then once I landed
I got very nervous all over again he
spoke further about the experience in an
interview with Yahoo entertainment
saying I felt unprepared the other
actors had been there for weeks and
months in some cases preparing for the
arduous task of shooting the whole
trilogy I also felt awkward because I'd
never been in a position of replacing
another actor Mortensen got right to
work when he arrived in New Zealand
immediately diving into the art of sword
fighting despite playing catch-up with
the other actors he became a consummate
swordsman while filming the trilogy
fitting right in with the rest of the
cast you have my
[Music]
my ax it seems like everyone was reading
Twilight and the lead-up to its film
adaptation in 2008. but Billy Burke was
not one of those people that was a
little strange considering he was cast
in the movie as Charlie Swann the father
of Moody protagonist Bella Burr
committed that he hadn't even heard of
The Twilight Saga when he was approached
about playing Charlie he told collider I
had no idea what Twilight was at all
Katherine Hardwick had seen a movie that
I did a number of years ago called Dill
scallion and she requested to have me in
I came in and we talked a little bit
about it and we read a couple of scenes
in the movie Sense we both fell in love
at that moment in another interview this
time with MTV Burke stated I read bits
and pieces of Twilight as we were making
it I'm just not a good reader so I
haven't been able to sit down and get
myself through an entire book in my
whole life Burke also wasn't prepared
for the franchise's Rabid fan base the
actor told the independent I've been
working in this business for a long time
and these kind of things only come along
once in a while where it becomes a part
of popular culture there are a lot of
worse things to be than Charlie Swann
yeah he wanted to meet you
officially
all right
bring him in
Christopher Plummer had essentially no
time to prepare for his role in all the
money in the world the reason no one in
its crew had time to prepare for the
revelations about Kevin Spacey that came
out during the film's production in the
thick of the hashtag metoo reckonings
that rocked Hollywood in 2017 Spacey was
fired from the film about the 1973
kidnapping in which the oil tycoon J
Paul Getty refused to pay the ransom for
his grandson what complicated matters
was that Spacey played J Paul Getty and
the film had already wrapped production
a scrambling Ridley Scott tapped plumber
to replace Spacey with plans to
reassemble the cast for nine days of
reshoots alongside the new Getty Scott
offered to let Plummer watch the scrap
Spacey footage but the sound of music
legend declined he explained to The
Hollywood Reporter it doesn't do an
actor any good to watch someone else
when you take over a part in the theater
it's better that you don't go and see it
first so you're not influenced in any
way the role comes from you I saw some
of the kidnapping stuff which I thought
was very well done but that's all I saw
bits and pieces that didn't involve J
Paul Getty at all plumber who died in
2021 played several notable historical
figures during his career including
writer Rudyard Kipling journalist Mike
Wallace in a claimed Russian novelist
Leo Tolstoy it makes sense then that he
had developed a method for such roles he
elaborated try and look and move like
the creature you're playing and try to
get their voice if you can but don't
over make up or do too many tricks
because then it looks like an imitation
despite having almost no time to prepare
plumber was nominated for an Oscar for
his performance in the film
Marlon Brando turned in numerous
astounding performances in films like on
the waterfront and The Godfather from
the 50s to the 70s but by the time the
90s rolled around he was mostly checked
out Brando reportedly didn't bother to
read the script of the 1996 sci-fi
Adventure the island of Dr Moreau he
arrived a week late for filming after
the suicide of his daughter insisted on
changes to the script that he hadn't
even studied and relied heavily on a
stand-in to do many of his scenes when
he was on set the film Legend simply
refused to memorize his lines they were
relayed through an earpiece by an
assistant which resulted in confusion at
least once when a signal was interrupted
by a police scanner the actor's bizarre
demands further disrupted in an already
troubled production that lost its
original director Richard Stanley within
days of beginning production Brando did
his own makeup hid in his trailer and
insisted that a particular extra become
roast constant companion in the film
when all was said and done the 1996 Dr
Morrell remake would earn the notoriety
of becoming one of the most disastrous
film Productions of its time this is the
most
outrageous spectacle I have ever
witnessed look at yourself Stanley and
the director who replaced him John
frankenheimer both were excited to work
with Brando but the actress Antics and
lack of preparation contributed to the
culture of hostility that the curse
production maintained Ewan McGregor
didn't read Jane Austen's novel Emma
before taking on the role of Frank
Churchill in the 1996 adaptation
alongside Gwyneth Paltrow he also
thought he was terrible in the role and
even some of his biggest fans would
agree McGregor told the guardian I made
the decision to do that film because I
thought I should be seen to be doing
something different from Trainspotting
my decision making was wrong it's the
only time I've done that and I learned
from it typically McGregor is an actor
who prepares thoroughly for his roles
for Trainspotting the Scottish actor
lost 30 pounds and shaved his head to
look convincing as an Irish drug addict
for Moulin Rouge he joined the rest of
the cast for a two-week dancing and
singing Workshop six months before
production began McGregor was equally
dedicated to portraying Kurt Wild and
embodying the Swagger of a rock star and
Todd Haynes Glam Rock fantasy velvet
gold mine that made Emma something of an
outlier the actor joked it's a good film
Emma but I'm just not very good in it
arriving on set intentionally unprepared
for a role may not seem like the best
game plan but for Girl Meets World
veteran Sabrina Carpenter it was a way
to help her play an equally unprepared
character in the 2020 Netflix dancing
flick work it she told l in 2020 a lot
of the times I would have learned the
choreography I'd learned it but not to
the point where it was muscle memory
playing a character learning how to
dance to get into her dream College
Carpenter needed to make it look like
she had two left feet it was a big ask
considering that Carpenter herself grew
up dancing her solution learned just
enough to be able to convincingly act
like someone who knows nothing she joked
I learned it to the point where I
wouldn't run into people but I didn't
always know what move was coming next
Carpenter participated in a two-week
training Workshop before filming began
but her has a tendency to take it
further rendered her character awkward
and clumsy throughout the film when she
finally does find her Rhythm she
discovers that life is full of pleasant
surprises
upon replacing the late Richard Harris's
elbow stumbledore for Harry Potter and
the Prisoner of Azkaban Michael Gambon
didn't read the novels the films were
adapted from before arriving on set for
the third film in the franchise while
promoting Harry Potter and the
Half-Blood Prince in 2009 he said to the
Los Angeles Times you'd get upset about
all the scenes as missing from the book
wouldn't you no point in reading the
books because you're playing with
screenwriter Steve club's words Gambon
also pointed out that his co-stars Ray
fines and Alan Rickman also chose not to
read the books while this might be the
norm for the Potter films Christopher
Lee and Ian McKellen who portrayed the
wizard Saruman and Gandalf in The Lord
of the Rings deeply loved tolkien's
novels some fans were not happy with
gambon's portrayal of the wizard
pointing out how the character became
more Fierce and Loud once Gambon took on
the role
however Gambon has always contended that
his portrayal of Dumbledore in the film
franchise was intentional he continued
he's got to be a bit scary all
Headmasters should be a bit scary
shouldn't they a top wizard like him
would be intimidating and ultimately
he's protecting Harry essentially I play
myself a little Irish a little scary
that's what I'm like in real life
[Music]